like to get to the topic of free will as
well and then also some audience
questions so why don't you donald
outline your views on free will
okay uh
yeah if
in a physicalist framework
which i so now i'll just talk about what
most of my
cognitive neuroscience peers think right
most of them assume that that physical
systems are fundamental
neural activity causes
um all of our behavior
and
in in that case
there can be a fiction of a useful
fiction of of free will but but it's
really just going to be a useful fiction
if i do something it's really my neurons
with the neural activity
that that did it and
um there is a sense in which you can say
i chose to do it because actually
veterans are part of me so i
i think that's the point of view that
dan dennett takes for example on this
and
and
and and sam harris you know replies on
that he says well yeah i also grow my
fingernails i'm not sure that i'm doing
that by free will but you know what
so so it's not real clear that just
because my neurons are doing it i have
free will just in the same sense that
i'm not using free will to grow my my my
fingernails um
so
so sam would say there's no such thing
as as free will if you're a physicist
dan dennett would say i'm a physicalist
and there is this important notion of
free will
um
i i think that of course space-time
isn't fundamental and so that we have to
completely think outside of that box all
together
and
as as scientists we have to
say front what are hypotheses what our
axioms or
fundamental assumptions are
and and be very clear about them up
front
these conscious agents
in the mathematics they they get certain
inputs we call them experiences that
they have
and then they they there's a something
called a markovian kernel that that
describes what actions they take and
those actions affect the experiences of
other conscious agents
so so then there's so that's just the
mathematics that that my team has
written down it's a very simple notion
of a markovian dynamics of conscious
agents interacting
and and it's not in the physical spring
work
we're assuming that this is
you know in its own world right these
are conscious agents
and and that's the foundation space and
time are not the foundation conscious
agents so conscious experiences and
interactions of conscious agents are the
foundational notion
and
so then the question is how shall we
understand
the probabilities so if i get a
particular experience that that comes
into a conscious agent
and it then
probabilistically affects the experience
of other agents how shall i
understand that probability
that it
shall i understand it as as a free will
choice
or or what
and
you know i could say you know i refuse
to answer the question i just there's a
probability there and that's that's as
far as i go with with a theory there's
you know this agent
so i leave that probability as just um
where my theory stops right i say
in some sense wherever we see a
probability in a theory that's where
explanation stops
right
that's that's basically saying
i don't know like my so whenever so i
said this whenever in a scientific
theory you see probabilities coming up
um
you're seeing the theory say this is
where i halt
uh this is where my explanation stops
and there are two major
approaches toward understanding those
probabilities the objectivist and
subjectivist
to probabilities right so
objectivists say that these
probabilities are
pointing to some real
thing in the world there is some real
random generator in the world
and subjectively say no
these are just degrees of belief
whenever you see probabilities
you're only talking about
degrees of belief
um but
in either case
explanation stops right how do i come to
that belief well i can only tell you
probabilities what is that random
objective process i don't know but i can
just tell you um probabilities and so so
really whenever you see probabilities in
the scientific theory and they're all
over the place
i read that as saying here's where
explanation stops um and our theories
our theories halt
and and if we want to go further we're
going to have to unpack that probability
into some some deeper
deeper theory
so
if i say that it's
free will
in the case of the conscious agents
um
then i mean
in some sense that's just words
what what the theory has is the
probabilities and it has no further
explanation so if i say if i call the
probability of a free will
then i you know i can call it that but
but i haven't really done much to
[Music]
give much insight into the notion of
free will free will then becomes a
primitive and and maybe that's what i
want to do i want to say um this is
where explanation stops and so free will
is primitive so when these probabilities
are our free will and i agree to that
that's where my theory stops that i i
can do no further
um
now what's interesting in the in the the
conscious agent dynamics that we're
working on is that um
any group of conscious agents
together also satisfy the definition of
a conscious agent and so they are a
conscious agent so any conscious agents
interacting are also conscious agents so
they're in the theory there's one
conscious agent
because if you take all of them together
they form one conscious agent but then
there are as many
um if you're computational there's only
accountable number of them where in my
case i don't know if it may be an
uncountable number of of conscious
agents but what's interesting is that
the you unpack this probability in the
markovian kernel there there could be
one big probability for the one agent
but you can unpack that into all these
dynamical systems interacting conscious
agents with their own probabilities and
their own kernels and what's what's
interesting is that you could then
give in some sense an unpacking of the
notion of free will in that way you
could say well yeah the one agent has
free will and this this probability but
i can actually
do some non-trivial unpacking of that
notion in this sort of recursive
unwinding of those probabilities um
throughout the network so so
there is the possibility here
of i mean ultimately
um there will be a primitive notion of
free will that that is just primitive
and not explained but given that one i
can explain all these other free wills
sort of interacting
arising from this most primitive notion
of free will in a non-trivial
non-trivial way but but once again i i
would i would point out
something that i see all the time in
scientific theories no theory in science
will ever explain everything
and and and i would love to see if
joshua
agrees disagrees i i will i'll just
state to make a strong claim
um
there cannot be a theory of everything
because every theory has to make
assumptions and those assumptions
are not explained they're assumed it's
just that simple
okay am i correct in my
summary of your views on free will that
if in a physical theory you have
probability now some of that probability
is just due to our ignorance but if
there's a fundamental probability you
can just say well that's indicating that
the theories break down we just don't
know or you can say that there's
something underneath producing those and
that which is underneath the
probabilities is what you're calling
free will is that correct or is that off
right so if i'm a physicalist i'll say
that that probability is due to some
process that i can say no more about but
there's some process that generates this
stuff it's not free will it's just a
physical process that that um i don't
know but if i'm taking consciousness to
be fundamental then it's an interesting
move to say that that that free that
that probability um can be interpreted
as
free will now of course i'm not
explaining anything i'm not you mean
i'm just putting the frame for the
notion free will the word free will on
it right
and and and free will becomes just a
a primitive notion as well i'm so that's
where my explanation stops and i'm the
most unpacking i can do is that
recursive unpacking that i that i
mentioned which is an interesting
unpacking but ultimately there's this
primitive notion of free will that i
have nothing further to say about but
but i think that um
that's not
a problem specific to this theory i the
last thing i was saying was that that's
endemic to all scientific theories every
scientific theory will have miracles at
its foundation by miracles i mean
assumptions that are taken for granted
and not explained
if you explain them then you'll have a
deeper theory with new assumptions that
explain those assumptions but the new
assumptions aren't explained and so so
in this sense
science can never have a theory of
everything because science
theories always have assumptions and the
assumptions are what you don't explain